[MUSIC pLAYING]
LAURA MURPHY: All
right, hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for attending
today's talk at Google here
in the Birmingham office,
soon to be Detroit office.
We are so fortunate and lucky to
have Aaron Foley with us today.
He is the newly appointed
chief storyteller
for the city of Detroit
in the mayor's office.
Why don't I turn it over to you
to give us a little bit more
about your background?
AARON FOLEY: Sure.
Well, I wasn't born in Detroit,
but I'm a native Detroiter.
And I was raised in the city.
I went to school in the city.
I always wanted
to be a journalist
and worked at a
couple of places.
I was the editor of a
small magazine here called
"BLAC," Black Life,
Arts, and Culture,
We distributed it around
our tricounty area
here in metro Detroit.
And I worked at
Team Detroit right
before they switched over
to GTB, held another couple
of writing posts.
I was freelancing.
I was writing essays.
I was just doing a lot of
stuff, and I was really,
really engrossed in
talking about Detroit
and where Detroit is right now
from the perspective of someone
who has lived through a
lot of things in Detroit.
So a lot of things that have
been written about Detroit
vary in perspective.
But there was very--
in my opinion,
there wasn't a lot
of native voices
talking about the city.
So I just started doing it.
LAURA MURPHY: And it's
interesting, Aaron,
that you say you
weren't born in Detroit.
I don't know that
I've read anywhere,
if you've shared where that is.
Do you care to
share that with us?
AARON FOLEY: Yeah, I was
born in Nuremberg, Germany.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, wow.
AARON FOLEY: So there's
a US Army base there.
My parents were in
the army, and that's
how I ended up born there.
But I didn't learn to
speak German or anything.
And the year I was born
is when the United States
changed the laws, in '84.
I just missed the
cut off where you
could have dual citizenship.
I, unfortunately,
do not have dual.
LAURA MURPHY: Well,
I was actually
going to save this question.
But because you
said Germany, it's
sparking a thought in my mind.
You wrote your first book,
"How To Live In Detroit
Without Being a Jackass" right
as the idea of gentrification
was becoming a social
norm conversation.
But what's interesting is
it's not a new concept.
You can trace it
all the way back
to, actually, Germany and Berlin
and a couple of other Eastern
European cities.
That's where the original
premise around it
became very, very important
to have as a conversation.
When I read your first book, I
get a lot of tips on Detroit,
but I actually see
the bigger structure
around maybe making this a
guidebook for other cities
that are going through
gentrification right now.
So I'm just curious.
Do you agree with that?
Do you think that
your first book
could become a template
for Philly and Oakland
and some other cities
that are experiencing what
Detroit has been going through?
AARON FOLEY: It could be.
I think the key thing is that
a book about Detroit, I think,
can--
I won't say can only be
written by a Detroiter,
but it helps if you
have someone who
is very familiar
with what Detroit was
and what direction
it's headed in.
But someone who is
not from Philadelphia,
someone who is not from Oakland
and trying to interpret Oakland
for other people who are
curious about Oakland,
it may not go over
as well, I think.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, definitely.
AARON FOLEY: But
then the other part
of that, too, is every city
has a very unique story.
Every city has its
own unique challenges.
Gentrification in
Detroit is going
to look a lot different than
gentrification in Oakland.
It's going to look a lot
different than Philadelphia,
New York, Austin.
It's what the challenges are,
and how do you interpret them?
So one thing I try
to point out is
that with Detroit,
we are very far away
from the kind of gentrification
you've seen in Brooklyn,
you've seen in
Austin, you've seen
in San Francisco and
whatnot, because the city is
so very empty, right?
There's currently about 680,000
people living in Detroit.
The population at its
peak was 2 million.
So there's about a million and
a half empty spaces in Detroit.
So it's kind of hard
to gentrify when
there are very few places
to be pushing people out.
But we do have the concern of
rising rents and rising costs
of living and things like that.
So there's a number
of things going on.
Like I said, I think Detroit
has sort of learned the lesson
from some of the other cities.
So we're trying to head some of
these things off at the pass.
So that's sort of what makes
our story different than,
like I said, in Oakland or
Philly or anything like that.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
and it's funny
that we are mentioning
all these other cities,
when on the cover of
the book, you say,
"please do not call
us the next Brooklyn."
AARON FOLEY: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: So can
you tell us a little bit
about how that kind of--
I don't know if got under
your skin was the word,
but I'd love to know
more about that.
AARON FOLEY: So no offense
to "The New York Times"
or the BuzzFeeds or the--
rest in peace--
Gawkers or anything
like that who lots of great
writers and journalists
worked for these publications.
Don't get me wrong.
But I feel like a lot of the
especially coastal publications
are always in search
of the "next Brooklyn"
and the new Brooklyn.
And they've applied that label
to New Orleans and Austin
and any city that side
of Cleveland, any city
that all of a sudden
becomes trendy.
You see a lot of
hipsters moving into it.
LAURA MURPHY: Hipsters,
there's the word.
AARON FOLEY: Moving to
a certain neighborhood.
And I spent time
in Williamsburg.
I know what
Williamsburg looks like,
and Williamsburg does
not look like Detroit.
And so I feel strongly that
Detroit is just Detroit.
We should not be taking on
an identity of another city.
People are trying to call
us the next Silicon Valley,
and I feel like Silicon
Valley should own that label.
Detroit should-- and
Detroit is evolving too.
Don't get me wrong.
We were Motown.
We were the Motor City
and things like that.
I'm not saying we have
to banish these labels
or hold onto them so tight.
But at the same time,
there's a reason
why we've identified
with these labels.
It's because it's something
that's natural to us.
It's something that we can own
and something we can claim.
And so when you try
to say the Detroit is
new Brooklyn, and even
Brooklyn 20 years ago,
40 years ago, wasn't the
Brooklyn that it is now.
And what does that say about us?
LAURA MURPHY: It is a
conundrum, for sure.
I'm interested, too,
in the process that you
used to go through this book.
Because as I was
reading it-- and I know
we're talking a lot
about the first book.
We'll get to the second
book in a second.
As I was reading
this, almost nothing
is out of bounds for you.
And I love that you have
how-to chapters in the book,
like how to party
like a Detroiter,
how to be gay in Detroit,
how to be a woman in Detroit,
how to raise a child in Detroit.
But a couple of those things,
I have to just say, point out,
they're not things that you are
very intimately familiar with.
So can you tell us
about the process
and how you research
things that--
unless you are a parent.
I believe you're not.
AARON FOLEY: No.
LAURA MURPHY: And I
know you're not a woman.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: So--
AARON FOLEY: Yeah,
I'm not a woman.
Some of the titles were a
little bit tongue in cheek.
Like I know I'm a guy,
and I have no kids,
and I was born a male.
But when I wrote "how to
be a woman in Detroit,"
I talked about how
sometimes women in Detroit
can get the short
end of the stick
sometimes because Detroit can
be a little misogynist at times.
I really hate to say it.
I mean, that's kind
of a strong word.
But we can treat our
women the wrong way.
I think about how there's
been a few political scandals
in Detroit, and the women
always go down as the mistress.
And she was the one,
all that type of stuff,
not to get too far into it.
But I look at the way
how women sometimes
get demonized sometimes for
their actions in Detroit, even
no matter what they do, right?
So it's just caution as far as--
here is where we are right
now in terms of culture,
in terms of attitude.
It's a very
unfortunate statistic
that domestic violence is
very prevalent in Detroit,
unfortunately.
But a lot of that can be tied
to a lot of systemic things
like unemployment and toxic
masculinity and all these types
of things that are just kind
of intertwined together.
So those are some of the
things that I talk about.
Talking about being
a parent in Detroit,
it's no secret that the
school systems in Detroit
have undergone a massive
amount of change.
The public school system
I went to 15, 16 years ago
is not the same as it is now.
In fact, in the three years
since the book came out,
there were two public
school systems.
When I was in school,
there was one.
Then it split off into two.
Now they folded back
into one, so now I
have to update the book again.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, wow.
Yeah, that's right.
I remember that.
AARON FOLEY:
Because there's been
so much turmoil in the schools,
so again, a lot of people
come to Detroit with the
idea, oh, the cost of living
is so affordable.
And I can afford
to raise a child.
I can afford daycare.
I can have disposable income.
But just a great precaution, the
schools may not be up to par.
There's a lot of overcrowding.
There's a lot of, at the time--
LAURA MURPHY: Lack of teachers,
and resources, and funding.
AARON FOLEY: --lack of
teachers, resources.
At the time when
I wrote it, they
were dealing with
rats in the schools
and all these types of things.
And schools are sort
of getting better.
There's a new superintendent
now and all of that.
But in my opinion, it might
take a whole generation
before we start to see
some of the changes that
are being implemented now.
LAURA MURPHY:
Interesting about gender,
such a hot topic right now.
This is just your
opinion, but do you
think that the
automotive industry can
be somewhat misogynist
as well just because
of its origins and its
roots all the way back
into the early days
of Henry Ford and men
really becoming the pioneers
behind the automotive industry?
Do you see that as a
part of the influence
of the misogynist culture
in Detroit as well?
AARON FOLEY: Oh, absolutely.
There was that report.
I don't know if you saw.
It was either the "Chicago
Tribune" or "The New York
Times."
But it was in Chicago,
which is why I don't
know which paper it was in.
But they interviewed-- this
was the height of #MeToo--
and they interviewed all
these female plant workers,
and they were just
describing the endless amount
of abuse and harassment that
they were enduring at a time
at a plant, a Ford
plant, out in Chicago.
There's no doubt that it happens
across the automotive industry
as far as what women
have to deal with.
But it is sad.
There's a lot of
things that we have
to unlearn, especially as men--
LAURA MURPHY: I
love that, "things
that we have to unlearn as men."
It requires that huge shift in
thinking, very much so, yeah.
AARON FOLEY: One thing I talk
about a little bit in the book
is how when we talk about the
concept of unlearning things,
a lot of Detroit's population
has roots in the South.
A lot of Detroit's
population were black people
that came from the South, and
you're coming from the South
with this mindset.
And I'm not talking about
in the South in 2018.
I'm talking like 100
years back, where
there was a lot of survival.
It was survival by
any means necessary.
And sometimes that meant
"the man of the house,"
and the man of the household
having a very heavy hand,
being very strict, putting
women in their place and things
like that.
There was also a religious
aspect to it as far as people
believing that the Bible
says man is the head,
and women submit, and all
these types of things.
And a lot of that came
up from the South.
I'm not saying it's
because of the South,
but it came up to the Midwest,
Chicago, St. Louis, Detroit
especially, Bay City, Saginaw,
Kalamazoo, all these places
where black people landed
during the Great Migration.
And a lot of that
persists today.
You can go into a
church now and still
hear people say man is
head of the household,
women submit to the man, and
all these types of things.
And as Detroit evolves, I hope
some of that thinking evolves
with it.
LAURA MURPHY: What
you're talking about,
too, there is the notion behind
immigration, which we could
tie back to gentrification.
So I wonder around the
topic of immigration,
do you see us being a city that
continues to attract people
not just from the South
domestically here in the US,
but globally?
Do you see city as a global
economies of scale city,
and we can continue
growing so we can get back
to that 2 million number?
AARON FOLEY: I would hope so.
It's my firm belief that
immigrant populations are not
only the backbone
of American society,
but if you look at a city
like Detroit that is so empty,
it makes more sense
that immigrants
can fill these empty spaces.
Detroit has always been
a hub for immigration.
People usually think of
the Ellis Island story
or coming to your San Franciscos
and LAs and things like that.
But if you look at the first
wave of the Hungarians,
the Italians, the Polish,
the French that came here,
and then the second wave, the
Latino Americans, and then
you break that down to
the Mexican Americans,
the Salvadorans, the
Venezuelans, and things
like that, and then the
Arab American population
that we have here coming from
Lebanon, Yemen, Iraq, Iran,
all of these places that sort
of have a commingling here.
Now we have a growing
West African population.
We have a growing West
Indian population.
All of these things contribute
to what Detroit's culture is.
I love the fact that I can
go to a Caribbean restaurant.
go to an African restaurant
and a Middle Eastern restaurant
all within a few miles
of each other here in Detroit.
So yeah, let's bring more
immigrants to Detroit.
LAURA MURPHY: Let's do that.
AARON FOLEY: Bangladeshi, too.
LAURA MURPHY: Let's
keep making this city.
AARON FOLEY: I can never forget
we have a whole Banglatown now.
LAURA MURPHY: And that
actually, in the chapter
where you talk about how to
be a parent in Detroit, one
thing that struck me that I just
love so much, and I want to--
hopefully as the chief
storyteller for Detroit,
you can continue this.
Just continue to educate the
young people, our children,
in other words, as parents, to
be open to race, to be open.
And diversity and inclusion
at any company, at any school,
in any subculture is the
most important thing.
So has that always
been something
that you have been keenly aware
of, diversity and inclusion?
And was it something you
were taught as a child?
AARON FOLEY: It was
one of those things
that you don't realize
how much it was taught
to you until you get older.
So I always went to
mostly black schools
growing up in a
mostly black city.
And Black History Month
was Black History Month,
but we talked about black
history all year long.
We were reading African-American
literature all year long
and all these types of things.
And I didn't realize.
I was just like, oh, gosh.
I didn't have to
wait till February
to read "The Bluest Eye."
LAURA MURPHY: It's just life.
AARON FOLEY: It's just life.
And a part of that is writers
like Toni Morrison, Maya
Angelou, were
speaking of urban life
that can apply to many different
urban cities like Detroit.
But also I think it helps
having teachers that--
I always credit my English
teachers and things like that--
who had that forethought
to say, hey, these kids
are going to go out
into the world, where
here in Detroit,
everyone looks like us,
but you go out into
outside of Detroit,
they don't look like us.
So let's instill an
appreciation for their culture
during their younger years.
But an underlying theme
throughout the book
is there's going to
be a lot of people
who are not black moving.
It'll be white.
It'll be Asian.
It'll be Latino, whoever, coming
into one of the few cities
in America, one of
the few major cities
in America, that
is mostly black.
It kind of goes both ways.
A lot of people may
not be used to that.
A lot of black people--
again, growing up in
mostly black neighborhoods
and going to mostly black
schools, when they see someone
that is not like them, they
may not know how to react,
but vice versa.
I think the onus also
falls on the newer person.
And how do we meet each
other in the middle here?
I think the end goal is we're
all here in Detroit, right?
So let's live together.
Let's understand each other, and
let's move this city forward.
LAURA MURPHY: Absolutely.
I love that.
You said even, too,
just for a baseline--
as people who grew up in Detroit
from all the different parts
of Detroit, one of the
things that you all do
is ask each other what
high school you went to.
AARON FOLEY: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: So not as to judge
someone or put them in a box,
but just to kind of get
their frame of reference
if you're East Side or
if you're West Side.
I love that you mentioned that.
But do you think
that that's something
that's specific to Michiganders
or Detroiters more so?
AARON FOLEY: I think it's
more specific to Detroiters.
Because Troy, for instance,
one of the suburbs,
you either went to Athens
or you went to Troy.
LAURA MURPHY: That's it, yeah.
AARON FOLEY: I have friends
from Troy, so I know.
But I feel like--
I won't say all places
outside of Detroit,
but I feel like a lot of places
outside of Detroit, people
forget about high school
the moment you leave.
And a lot of people
leave their hometowns.
And it's just like, oh, my high
school friends on Facebook.
I just left them
behind or whatever.
But here in Detroit, you
grow up in the neighborhood
that you went to high
school, and sometimes you
end up living in the
neighborhood after that you
went to high school in.
And you end up still dialoguing
with a lot of people, maybe not
in your graduating
class, but definitely
who were in the building
at the same time you were.
So it's kind of like an
unofficial formality.
It's just like instead of
asking where you're from,
we can deduce where
you're from by asking
what high school did you go to.
And it's also the fact
that Detroit is very large,
but it's very small.
If I go to someone and say,
oh, you went to Mumford,
do you know so-and-so?
Do you know so-and-so?
Do you know-- this
is breaking the ice.
LAURA MURPHY: It is.
It is.
AARON FOLEY: It's networking.
LAURA MURPHY: It's making
connections and networking,
absolutely.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: It's so true.
You mentioned Facebook.
So I have to take
a chance to talk
to you a little bit
about using social media
not only to promote yourself
but some of these amazing things
you're doing.
And I spent some time looking
at some of your social media.
You do an incredible job
with staying above the board.
I think that's what it is.
You get a lot of comments,
especially on your Twitter
page, from people who
saw you in a Ted Talk
or saw you do an interview.
And they maybe
disagree with you.
How do you find the balance?
Because as a parent
and a Googler,
social media runs through
every thread of my day.
AARON FOLEY: It does, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: So how
do you personally
find the balance with what's
right for social media as Aaron
Foley as a person and as now
in a big role at the mayor's
office?
AARON FOLEY: There's
admittedly been a shift
since I started working
for the mayor's office,
because one of the things prior
to working for the mayor's
office, I tried to engage with
everyone, even the trolls.
LAURA MURPHY: Love
them or hate them.
AARON FOLEY: And you got
to engage with everyone.
And I reached the point.
I mean, even before
social media,
part of my journalism
training was
you can't convince
everybody what's right.
There's always
going to be someone
who will always disagree,
especially if you
put your opinion out there.
One thing I do appreciate
is that people are
so passionate about Detroit.
The smallest thing
can set someone off.
And that's a good thing.
You should have that same
kind of passion and energy
about everything in Detroit.
So I would engage with everyone.
I was just like, hey, this
is where I'm coming from.
Here are some of the
facts to back it up,
or here are some
of the things I've
experienced to back this up.
And I always say, well, if
you have a different opinion,
state it.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
I saw you say that.
Great, keep it coming, yeah.
Yeah, you embrace people's
very bad opinions.
AARON FOLEY: After working
for the mayor's office though,
you do have to be a
little more diplomatic.
Because one of the
things I said very
early on is that I'm not
just representing myself
at this point.
Or you can always put in
your Twitter bio or any bio,
"retweets are not opinions."
But when you are presenting
a local county or state
government or a
federal government,
you just can't pop off
at everybody, especially
if they're a resident of the
constituency that you serve.
I'm not an elected official,
but I am very public.
So the last thing I want is
to embarrass my colleagues,
embarrass the administration,
embarrass the city.
Everybody is always looking
for something to go viral,
and I don't want to be the
person that gets a headline
and says, "city
official mouths off
on Twitter against
poor Detroit resident"
or something like that.
LAURA MURPHY: What is your
social media of choice?
Which one do you find
yourself as an active consumer
mostly, if you do?
AARON FOLEY: It's funny.
I pick it based on the audience.
So I'm embracing LinkedIn
a little bit more.
I don't post a lot on LinkedIn,
but I should start doing that,
because I notice a lot of
professional connections.
That's what LinkedIn
is made for,
but it's interface now is
more social and whatnot.
So I need to start posting more
videos and things like that,
some of the things
we're doing at the city.
Nextdoor, the team I
manage at the city,
we signed up for
Nextdoor last week.
And man, don't get me wrong.
It's great.
But it's a different world.
So you can't dialogue
the same on Nextdoor
as you do with a LinkedIn
or Facebook or Twitter.
I personally love
Twitter the most,
just because I feel like
Twitter is where you can get--
and I looked at how other
city officials and how
other people in other cities use
Twitter-- and it's just like,
this is everything you're
going to get from me.
You're going to get
updates from my job.
You're going to get my
thoughts about a few things.
You're also going to get--
I want to jump in
in on a hashtag.
I want to live tweet a TV show.
I want to post a couple of GIFs.
I want to post a
couple of inside jokes
that only some of
my friends will get.
You can get just a little
bit, a sampling of everything,
on Twitter.
Facebook, though,
Facebook and Twitter,
it's kind of half and half.
Facebook is where I do
a lot of the promotion.
And I also use Facebook as
a community engagement tool
sometimes when I'm just trying
to get and gather some thoughts
about the city and Detroit.
Like, hey, what do you guys
think about this neighborhood
name?
Or hey, what are you guys--
I saw this.
Tell me if you're
seeing the same thing.
Every media has a
different function,
but those are the four,
know Facebook, Twitter--
I'm going to make sure I
didn't lose anything, because--
LAURA MURPHY: Insta,
Insta and YouTube.
AARON FOLEY: I can hear our
digital and social media
manager back over there
saying, but you forgot--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, that was
just a question about you
though, Aaron, so that's good.
Going back to the two books,
actually, to the process--
it's interesting.
Your first book was really
written by a party of one,
whereas your second
book, I believe,
you had 32 contributors
to that one.
How did that go?
How did you even
solicit those stories
about those neighborhoods?
Tell us a little bit about that.
AARON FOLEY: The publisher put
out a call for submissions.
Well, I should back
up a little bit.
So the first book that
came out about Detroit
through Belt Publishing
was a Detroit anthology.
The second was mine.
But one of the other
cities, Cleveland,
did a neighborhood guidebook.
And I was thinking to
myself, oh, Detroit
should have a
neighborhood guidebook.
Why does Cleveland get
to go before Detroit?
LAURA MURPHY: We're way cooler.
AARON FOLEY: And Detroit
has so many different kinds
of neighborhoods.
One of the things that
is pervasive throughout
the narrative of Detroit
is everything is downtown,
and then there's nothing
outside of downtown.
And people in Detroit
know that's not true.
So I said to
myself, why don't we
gather as many different
voices from across the city,
whether they live
in the city or not?
But just tell me something
about this far-flung East Side
neighborhood.
So tell me something about
this far-flung West Side
neighborhood, all these places
in between the two narratives.
Why don't we do it?
So we put out a call for
submissions, and we got a lot.
We got a lot.
And we had to narrow it down.
And actually, two
of the writers said
they want to do a part two.
And I was just like, you
guys can handle all of that,
because it was a--
LAURA MURPHY: Wait.
Do you have an
announcement to make today?
Are you writing part
two to that book?
AARON FOLEY: No.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, I was going
to say you could break it
here first if you are.
AARON FOLEY: I put the
bug in my publisher's ear,
and she's like, wait.
I do have an
announcement though.
The second edition of "How To
Live In Detroit Without Being
a Jackass" comes out this fall.
LAURA MURPHY: Ah, yay.
AARON FOLEY: So, and
it's going to have--
LAURA MURPHY: You heard
it here first, right?
Are we first?
AARON FOLEY: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: Yes, you
heard it here first.
Yay, good.
AARON FOLEY: So it'll have
a new cover and all that.
But my publisher said, well, you
got to get through this first
before you even think
about another book.
And I'm like, I'm not
thinking about another book.
LAURA MURPHY: I love this,
because this is obviously
the Verner's branding
that you used.
And it stands out.
And I wonder if you
know that, if you're
from outside of Detroit.
But are you doing the same
branding with your second book?
AARON FOLEY: I don't know.
LAURA MURPHY: Still
working on it?
AARON FOLEY: I'm working
the designer now,
and we were like--
Karen Dybis, another
local author,
wrote a book about Better Made.
And it has the Better Made logo.
And so she already
took that one.
And I was like, well,
maybe it could be Faygo.
And I was just
like, well, no, why
does it have to be another pop?
And I was thinking about
all these local brands,
like Motown and
Hudson's and something.
LAURA MURPHY: Motown, do Motown.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
But then people will think
it's a book about music,
and I don't want them
to think that, so yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: That's true.
But this wasn't a book
about soda pop, either.
AARON FOLEY: It wasn't.
The Verner's cover was--
I knew people in
Detroit would get it,
but I wanted, if it ever got--
which it ended up doing.
It got sold in Ohio and
Brooklyn and Chicago
and places like that.
I wanted, if you were from
Michigan or from the Midwest,
and you were in a
bookstore, and you
saw that, you would
immediately know
that it's got some
sort of Detroit
or Midwestern connection.
LAURA MURPHY: Totally, yeah.
Going back to what
we were just talking
about with the second
book, the guidebook.
You got tons of submissions.
What was one of the best ones,
if there's just a quick story,
that you couldn't
publish maybe you
could tell us about here today?
AARON FOLEY: One of the ones,
honestly, that I couldn't
publish was a photo essay.
And that was because
to print photo
through a small press,
and the distributor
that we were using at the
time and the book press
that we were using at the time,
it would have cost way more.
And we probably
would not have gotten
that return on investment.
But now that the
publisher is growing--
Belt is growing rapidly.
Every time you look
[INAUDIBLE],, the publisher,
is announcing a new book.
Now I wonder if there's
more funding to actually do
more photos in books.
But yeah, that was
something that was like,
ugh, I wish I could.
Because a few of
the contributors
also included photos with their
essays, and I kept saying,
I really, really wish we
could, but we can't do photos.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, we
wish you could too.
Maybe part two of
that book we well.
AARON FOLEY: I was going to
say, part two will have to--
if there is one, I'm not--
LAURA MURPHY: That's awesome.
All right, well, I
also read somewhere
that you host pub trivia nights.
AARON FOLEY: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: Is
there some place
that you do that regularly so
we can all come and play trivia
with you?
AARON FOLEY: Yes, every
Wednesday at six o'clock
at Firebird Tavern in Greektown.
My friend from college is the
operations manager for Quizzo.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
yeah, I love Quizzo.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah,
and I just love
to pretend to be
a game show host,
and you get to buy people
beer and all of that.
So it gets really
nerdy sometimes.
There's a whole team of
local trivia writers, right?
So they're always talking
about "Star Wars" and "Lord
of the Rings."
And I'm not saying that's nerdy,
but they get deep into it.
And sometimes the host
will have to get on them.
We're like, we know what
this means, but some of this
is going above the
heads of the people that
just want to play along.
So we had to tone it
down a little bit.
But they also get into a
lot of local questions,
like Red Wings
and local history.
LAURA MURPHY: I
was going to say it
would be so neat to do a
Detroit trivia night sometime.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah, I'm
going to pitch that to Mike
as soon as I get out of here.
LAURA MURPHY: Perfect.
We would love that.
That would be so great.
It wasn't shocking
to me when I read
that you do that because,
at least in your first book,
your first book lends itself
a lot to being a neighborhood
guidebook, like
your second book.
And then when I read that
you host this trivia night,
there were so many
things I learned.
Who knew that the Rencen
had a movie theater in it?
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: That's crazy.
Any who knew that there was
over 200 different neighborhoods
in Detroit?
So how do you know so much?
I know you're from Detroit,
but these smaller things
that go back to the research
process of your book,
was it just a ton of
visiting places and research?
AARON FOLEY: It was a
little bit of everything.
I was blessed to have a civics
teacher in high school--
her name was Ms. Wyatt--
who subtly taught us a
lot about Detroit history
in the grander scheme
of social studies.
And I was just really
fascinated about some
of the stuff she was saying.
She was talking about how
certain neighborhoods--
we were in high school, right?
This is stuff that's kind
of old hat to anybody
over the age of 45 in Detroit,
but talking about how former
neighborhoods used to be
Jewish before they were black
and all these types of things.
I was literally passing by a
church on the Northwest side
yesterday leaving a
community meeting,
and I believe it's
a Baptist church
or a Church of God and Christ.
But they still have the same
glass Star of David out front.
LAURA MURPHY: In
a Baptist church.
AARON FOLEY: And it's
clearly not a synagogue.
But I was just absorbing
all of these little bits
of information about Detroit.
And you go to a party
or something like that,
and you try to break the
ice with someone else.
And I'm always a nerd about it.
I'm just like, did you
know that Detroit has this?
And they're just looking
at me like, what?
And I was like, OK, I'm not
going to do that anymore.
Let me just write
down everything
I know and do some
additional research.
Because I say in
the very beginning,
I don't know everything.
But there's just a lot of stuff.
Detroit is very old.
It's more than 300 years old.
And it's gone through a
lot of different changes.
So there's a lot of different
things that need to be known.
And one of the
things I love to say
is that Detroit is
truly an American city,
but we don't think of
Detroit as an American city.
We don't have a Liberty Bell.
Or I spent a lot of time
in New York this year.
And people are always
just like, oh, you've
got to see the 9/11 Memorial.
You've got to see--
we don't have one of those
iconic American history things,
but we're very much part
of the American story.
We're a trading
post and building
sort of the backbone of that
economy, the Motor City,
being the arsenal of democracy,
all these types of things where
a lot of the American dream
and a lot of the American story
has played out in
Detroit, but we
don't get enough credit for it.
LAURA MURPHY: Right, absolutely.
And you even say
this in your book.
I think places like
the DIA and all
these wonderful
cultural destinations
that we have that I
think we take for granted
now, because we are such a
nice immigration melting pot.
AARON FOLEY: I was going to say.
The DIA does not
get enough credit.
LAURA MURPHY: No, it doesn't.
AARON FOLEY:
Because like I said,
people think of the big museums,
the MoMA and the Guggenheim
and things like that,
and they're always either
in LA or New York, right?
No one thinks of any city
in between the two biggest
cities as having world
class art museums.
But the DIA has world class art.
LAURA MURPHY: It's
similar to the DSO
being one of the most
spectacular symphony orchestras
I have ever been to.
We're just super fortunate.
Along those lines,
I think you are
familiar that we are moving
the Google office down
to downtown Detroit.
Curious, I have to
ask this question.
Any tips for Googlers, how to
move to Detroit without being
a jackass Googlers?
AARON FOLEY: OK, well,
you can use Google to--
LAURA MURPHY: You can use
Google, or you can think of--
I know this question gets asked
to the mayor's office a lot.
The biggest job right now
is getting big companies
like Google to come down, move
your full operations down.
We've seen Microsoft
do it recently.
We saw QuickenLoans
be one of the first
to do it several years ago.
So anything along
those topics at mind?
AARON FOLEY: Like I said,
you've got a world around you
in Detroit.
At LCA, a lot of
things are going
to be in walking distance, or in
some cases, the same building.
But you're also going to
be close to Mexicantown
in southwest Detroit.
So you can take 75
straight down and check out
all of the different
places down there.
If you're feeling
going out of the way,
there's a couple of
take out barbecue
places along the Lodge.
[INAUDIBLE],, or whatever
your preferred term
is-- it's the Lodge.
LAURA MURPHY: Just
like McNichols, 6 Mile.
AARON FOLEY: Yes.
But also, if there's a
chance, I'd also check out--
I'm passionate
about neighborhoods.
So LCA is right across
from Brush Park,
which just today
"The New York Times"
had the whole slide show
called "Detroit Was Crumbling,
Now It's Reviving.
Here's How."
The bulk of that slide
show was in Brush Park,
but also near downtown,
Indian Village, the Gold Coast
neighborhood, Rivertown
neighborhood, the River
Walk along Jefferson
Avenue, the upcoming
things that are coming
to Lafayette Park and all
of those East Side
neighborhoods.
If you go further north
along Wilbur, the North End--
the North End is actually
where my family settled
when they came up north.
And North End has gone
through its challenges.
A lot of Motown stars lived
there and things like that.
But over the years, the
neighborhood has sort of
crumbled a little
bit, but it's still
a very proud neighborhood.
It's home to a lot of the
techno, some of the more
cutting edge techno
artists here in Detroit.
And they do some of
these underground art
things over there
and things like that.
It's also a great place
to buy a very cheap house
and restore it.
So as development pushes
north, New Center on one side,
North End on the
other, those two areas
are probably going to
become more popular.
But there's always a lot
to explore in Detroit.
There's no doubt that
a lot of neighborhoods
have a long way to go,
but things are happening.
Things are happening
at a very rapid pace.
It's still not going
to happen tomorrow.
It's not going to
happen next year.
But something is
going to happen.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Those are some great tips.
So we'll have to make
sure we take that list
and get that distributed.
Oh, and then buy your second
book, since it'll be fall.
The two will coincide
nicely together.
One more thing back
to the topic of you,
because I mentioned that you
were a copywriter at Team
Detroit, now GTB.
We're very familiar
with that agency.
They're one of our
stellar partners
in the world of what
we do here at Google.
How did you make the
transition out of being--
did you work on
automotive business there?
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Probably 100%,
out of being an automotive
copywriter into--
and I know there is something in
between-- but this awesome job
you have now as the chief
storyteller at the mayor's
office.
AARON FOLEY: It was
a very twisted path
getting to Team Detroit.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
wow, getting there?
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
So it was sort of the last
place I thought I would end up.
But I was working as
an automotive reporter
at "Ward's Auto," which
is a trade publication--
it's in Southfield--
covering Chrysler.
And I was doing a lot of--
I wasn't just writing about
the business of Chrysler.
I was reviewing a lot of cars.
I was flying all over
the place and getting
to know all of the
automotive reporters
across different magazines
and things like that.
Things at "Ward's
Auto" were going great.
Then I got laid off from there.
But before I got laid
off from "Ward's Auto,"
I was freelancing
for "Jalopnik."
"Jalopnik" used to
be owned by Gawker.
Now it's owned by Univision.
I was writing about
Detroit for "Jalopnik,"
and I built an
audience that way.
So I used my freelancing
chops at "Jalopnik"
to wiggle my way into some
other freelancing gigs,
and that was keeping
me afloat for a while.
But I was thinking to myself,
I really want a full time job.
So freelancing is great.
Talking about Detroit is great.
But I missed going to
an office instead of
sitting in my PJs writing.
So I used some of my
automotive experience.
And I don't want to say
used, but I knew someone
at Team Detroit who
was working there.
And they said they
needed copy writers.
They especially needed
someone who knows
a little bit about automotive.
And I said, yeah, I can do that.
So I ended up at Team Detroit.
But copywriting,
while I loved it,
I liked working on the Ford
account and things like that.
I really missed journalism.
So I was still freelancing on
the side, kind of moonlighting
a little bit.
And one of the places
I was freelancing for,
"BLAC" magazine, their
editor's chair opened up.
And I was thinking to myself,
well, I'm going to try this.
I'm going to put my hat in the
ring and see if I can do this.
And I got that job.
So I went from journalism to
advertising back to journalism,
but then while I was
editing at "BLAC,"
I got a call from
the mayor's office.
Because all of the
freelancing that I had done,
and the book had just
come out and all of that,
he was reading a lot of it.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, nice.
Oh, the mayor read your book.
Wow, that's so
flattering, isn't it?
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
And I was like, oh,
well, that's cool.
LAURA MURPHY: I'll
take that call.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah, I'll take--
the chief of staff from the
mayor's office called and said,
let's have dinner.
I want to talk to you
about some things.
And I'm thinking
she's wanting to talk
to me about coverage of the City
of Detroit for the magazine.
I'm just like, oh,
yeah, I've been
waiting for this
conversation for a while,
because I was trying to
build the magazine up
to have a little bit more
of a foothold in Detroit
as much as it did
in the suburbs.
And she was like,
oh, no, we want
to talk to you about some new
things we've got going on.
And we think you'd be
perfect for this job.
And I thought about it.
I consulted with my parents.
And I was like, ugh, I don't
want to change jobs again.
I just--
LAURA MURPHY: You just
got this editor's job.
AARON FOLEY: Yeah.
And I was laid off
before, and it's also
during an election year.
And I was like, well,
what if the mayor
doesn't get re-elected?
What happens then?
And all these types of things--
and I was like, you know what?
I'm just going to
jump and do it.
You only get one chance
to do a job like this.
So after many, many,
many sleepless nights,
I took the job.
And I came up with
the job title myself.
LAURA MURPHY: Did you really?
AARON FOLEY: So there's other
chief storytellers out there,
but there wasn't one
in the City of Detroit.
And there was only
a few at the time.
I Googled it, and I think
Microsoft had someone,
and Delta Airlines has one.
But it wasn't a big job title.
Now, all of a
sudden, I don't want
to say I kicked off a trend.
But you're starting to see.
I see now either the job
title or storytelling
is in the job description.
LAURA MURPHY: What were
they hiring you to do?
Were they hiring you to
do something very similar?
AARON FOLEY: So they needed--
the mayor really wanted someone
who identified with Detroit
and could speak to what's
going on in Detroit
and has an eye for things
and bringing that to our cable
channel and our media services
department.
So that's where I am
housed is with the staff
that puts out public
access programming
and does the audio visual
engineering and things
like that.
The city has four
public access channels,
so we brought on two
videographers in addition
to the ones that
were already hired
to produce content
relating to the mission
that he had asked me to do.
So I send the two
videographers, the two writers,
and a photographer out
to just cover Detroit
as if we are a newsroom.
So we talk to
neighborhood leaders.
We talk to business owners.
We talk to residents.
We talk to churches,
nonprofits, all
of these different
types of things,
and try to get a full picture
of what's going on Detroit.
So we know there's
a lot of stuff
going on downtown
with the new arena
and in the QLine and
things like that.
And we know that there are
still some challenges that
need to be addressed in the
way of poverty, unemployment,
and crime.
But we also see the opportunity
to say, hey, let's not
forget about people who--
today, we did a
story about a woman
who's making it her
mission to enroll everybody
into a block club.
So these small
victories along the way
is what we also like to talk
about in our media services
department, and that's
how I ended up telling
these stories of Detroit.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
that's so interesting.
And even here at Google, if
you're not a self-promoter,
you're not really
rising to the top.
So it's interesting
that you've assumed
the position of
self-promoting Detroit,
not just domestically
too, but also it
seems like you've done some
cool things outside of Michigan
even, to really get
people to pay attention
to our great city.
AARON FOLEY: But I am very
fortunate that a lot of people
are very interested in the
Detroit story right now.
But I think what's
key is, again,
having someone that can
communicate from a Detroiter's
perspective.
I think for a very long time--
and this is not a
knock on anyone--
but a lot of Detroit's
story was being
told by people who were
very new to the city, who
were very green to the city.
And they were telling
their perspectives from--
I've lived in Detroit
for two years,
and I love my life in
the last two years.
And it's just like, but
what about the people
who have lived here for like
20, 30, 40, 50, 60 years?
It's very important
to have that balance
and have the dialogue
across the whole city,
not just a handful of people.
LAURA MURPHY: We are so
fortunate to have you
in that position, because you
bring the credibility of having
grown up here.
You've held a lot of number of
professional and freelance jobs
around the city.
And you just have the right
spirit and the right energy.
So thank you for
representing our city
so well as well as you do.
One last question for
you, Aaron, and tell us
what you can.
But mentioning the mayor's
office similar to Team Detroit,
GTB, they've been a
wonderful partner of ours
here at Google, a big supporter
of us moving downtown.
Is there one thing maybe
that we don't know about
that the mayor's office is
doing that's extra special?
Or maybe something
that we can know about
that you haven't had a
chance to write about yet
or really get out
there publicly?
AARON FOLEY: I think--
we talked about
it earlier as far
as gentrification and whatnot.
I think one of the things that
a lot of people don't know
is that there are a lot of
people in city government
who are very passionate
against making
sure gentrification
doesn't happen.
There's a lot of challenges.
You cannot fight the
free market, right?
But a lot of people don't know
that, for example, our housing
director has gone
to what we call
at-risk properties,
properties that
are at risk of going from a
fixed income affordable housing
to a market rate building.
So he's gone
building to building
to convince those landlords
to remain fixed income
or affordable for
the next 20, 30,
however long the contract is.
You have people like our
development team, which
just hired a Google
former employee who
are securing all of
these grants and things
like that to try and create
more affordable housing.
Because we know
that, like I said,
there is a lot of challenges
that have come generation
to generation to generation,
and we're living with them now.
And a lot of people cannot
afford to live in a city with
Chicago rents or
San Francisco rents.
So how do we do everything
we can on the government
side to make sure
that Detroit remains
affordable to all residents?
And that's something,
in my opinion, that
doesn't get out there enough.
The overwhelming fear, and
it's a very legitimate fear--
don't get me wrong.
It's a very legitimate
fear of getting pushed out.
fear of getting gentrified.
LAURA MURPHY: It's scary.
AARON FOLEY: Every
time a new restaurant
opens, the hairs on the back
of people's necks go up.
But I highly encourage
people to understand
that you have people that are
doing everything in their power
to make sure that people
are leaving Detroit faster
than they're coming in.
And there may not be somebody
ready to take their place.
So what do we do to
retain and preserve
quality, a better quality
of life for the Detroiters
that are here?
A key tenant of that is
creating and preserving
affordable housing.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, absolutely.
Housing is very important.
And then all of the shops that
have popped up along Woodward
too make it just an incredible
place to be right now.
It's so exciting.
AARON FOLEY: I really--
I'm going to put this out there.
It's not true.
So there was there was a
report a couple of weeks
ago that said H&M was coming.
I wouldn't mind if an H&M
comes, and I can neither confirm
nor deny.
However, you know what I
would love to see in Detroit?
I was just in New York.
I was just in Denver.
LAURA MURPHY: Uniqlo.
AARON FOLEY: Uniqlo.
LAURA MURPHY: It's
my favorite place.
I was hoping you were
going to say Uniqlo.
AARON FOLEY: This
is a Uniqlo shirt.
This is a Uniqlo shirt.
LAURA MURPHY: Uniqlo
is my favorite store.
I'm going to New York tomorrow.
It's on my list of things to do.
AARON FOLEY: And they only
have like, what, five stores
in the country?
And I'm just like--
LAURA MURPHY: Can you
help us get a Uniqlo here?
AARON FOLEY: That's why
I'm putting it out there.
So if you guys-- so use
your search engine magic,
and tag them in everything.
LAURA MURPHY: OK, all right, OK.
We'll work together on this.
AARON FOLEY: I'll say
Detroit is perfect for one,
because Detroit and
Denver are the same size.
We have the same population.
We have the same square footage.
And I think about--
Uniqlo is cheap.
LAURA MURPHY: It's amazing.
AARON FOLEY: It's just as cheap
as H&M. And I think about,
if we're talking about
issues of affordability
and things like that,
I think about kids
who need school uniforms, and
kids who need play clothes.
Put a Uniqlo downtown.
LAURA MURPHY: They
sell uniforms there.
Yeah, that's a good point.
And it's for men, women, kids.
AARON FOLEY: It's for everybody.
LAURA MURPHY: It's
for everybody.
Well, actually,
it's a good point.
AARON FOLEY: It's very selfish.
LAURA MURPHY: So that's
your retail wish list.
If you had-- gosh, we have so
many amazing places to eat,
even grocery stores that
have retained their heritage.
If you had one wish for, not a
chain, or it could be a chain,
but a type of restaurant that
we're missing or we're lacking,
what would you like
to see in the city?
AARON FOLEY: We're missing a
full scale Indian restaurant.
LAURA MURPHY: OK, all right, OK.
AARON FOLEY: When
I say full scale,
I mean with a bar, a
large amount of seating.
There's one or two.
The one I'm thinking
of is mostly take out.
If there's a second
one out there,
I can't think of
what it is right now.
But we're missing a full
scale Indian restaurant.
What else are we missing?
That's the main
thing I can think of.
I love Indian food, so.
LAURA MURPHY: I was just
at the Adventure Park,
actually, right along--
AARON FOLEY: Oh, the river.
LAURA MURPHY: I love it.
And that, I believe,
the Michigan DNR
actually sponsors that
along the River Walk.
And it got me to
thinking, Belle Isle
is one of our favorite places
to picnic and go to the aquarium
and take a walk
and whatever else.
And now we've got
the Adventure Park.
So in my opinion, I think we're
missing more places like that,
places for like big parties
or birthday parties or group
gatherings, group events.
So I don't know exactly
what that looks like,
but that would be
on my wish list.
AARON FOLEY: There's a few.
I think of Rouge Park
way on the West Side,
how much outdoor
space there is there.
I cannot call--
Balduck Park, Balduck Park
has a few outdoor activities.
I cannot think of
the name of the park,
but it's in
Banglatown, I believe,
where there's a Gaga ball park.
And apparently, unless
you have little kids,
nobody knows unless
you have kids.
And it's like a handball
but on the ground,
and it's a new sport
that only took off
in the last three years.
And there's video and photos
of the mayor playing Gaga.
And he's getting into it.
He had his sleeves rolled up.
I was like, whoa,
whoa, these are kids.
But we're starting to
see the parts turnaround
for the better.
For a long time, the
parks were neglected.
The city didn't have a lot of
money and things like that.
But we're starting to see
an uptick, and hopefully,
getting people outside.
There's a few parks
near where I live,
and I'll be honest, I don't
use them as much as I should,
because I'm a homebody.
But I feel like,
OK, I'm a city boy.
I should be using the
parks as well, so yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, it's
interesting with the move
of all of our sports teams.
All of our sports
teams are downtown now.
But then I love what Detroit has
done for the sport of soccer,
because that Detroit FC team
is just on fire right now.
It is all the buzz.
Everyone wants to
go see football.
AARON FOLEY: And I don't
go to the DCFC games,
but I really
appreciate what they've
done to bring more
awareness to soccer.
We've had interest
in MLB coming here.
And I don't know if we're
in the running for that,
but it would be great.
LAURA MURPHY: Ooh,
it would be so great.
AARON FOLEY: It would be great.
It would be great if we
had a major league and DCFC
peacefully coexist.
I know there's
some tension there.
But I think about the long term.
I think about our areas
like Southwest Detroit
and Banglatown where you
have large soccer-playing
populations.
And I played soccer
when I was a little kid.
And I'm thinking, the more
soccer we have, the better.
Let's get all
these kids playing.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, because
it is an international game.
But we won't show bias
towards our favorite sports.
So thank you so much,
Aaron, for being here today.
We really appreciate your time.
And if you haven't read his
book or either of his books,
make sure you check
them out as well as
the one that's on its
way out now this fall.
So thank you again.
Appreciate it.
AARON FOLEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]